OK.
Last Fox News clip for the day.
I'm going to play for you today, the video
that should be at the top of the list of videos
to scrub it from the Internet.
If you are the Trump administration and if
you are Fox News, it is a video of a woman
named Kaylee McKenny, who is a press secretary
for Donald Trump's 2020 campaign.
She's been around for a while commenting on
politics.
She's a big Christian right winger, often
saying painfully dumb things.
She went on Fox News a few weeks ago and said
not that the virus wouldn't be a big deal
here in the United States because of something
about its rate of spread or its death rate
or because of something about infectious disease
or a medication.
She went on and said on Fox News, Donald Trump
is America first.
He's not going to allow a virus like Corona
virus to come here.
And she added, that's refreshing compared
to the Obama administration.
This is what happens when you join a cult.
And she is in a cult.
And that's the right word here.
So the Trump campaign has been working hard
to scrub videos from the Internet of Trump,
referring to the virus as a hoax.
If I were them, I would do everything I can
to get this video off the Internet.
We're going to try to make it a little bit
harder by playing the video for you now.
This is Kaley McKenny being interviewed by
former Fox host Trish Regan.
Trish Regan has since been fired after going
on her own unhinged rant about the Corona
virus hoax.
This is the clip in question.
Take a look.
Looking at the coronavirus and the president
saying, now look what?
We're not gonna take people in from China
right now.
I mean, isn't it just a matter of protecting
our national security really being at stake
and he's sort of the last line of defense?
Well, first, I should say, absolutely.
This president will always put America first.
He will always protect American citizens.
We will not see diseases like the coronavirus
come here.
We will not.
See terrorism come here and isn't that refreshing
when contrasting it with the awful presidency
of President Obama.
Candy McInerney, thank you so much.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
Trish Regan there gleefully welcoming this
absolutely abortive and fetid claim by Kaley
McKenney.
This to me is more highly weaponized than
the dumb medical arguments that float around,
because this is the type of argument that's
actually immune to reality and facts.
It's an argument like we've seen.
So let me give you an example of arguments
that we've seen.
This is less of a concern than the flu because
it is less deadly.
That's wrong.
But it's not immune to the facts.
Right.
Most of the people or many of the people saying
it don't care about the facts, but you can
deal with it.
You can say, oh, well, you know, the flu death
rate is point 1 5.
The death rate for the virus appears to be
between point seven and 1.5.
It's somewhere between 5 and 10 times deadlier.
OK.
You don't need the social distance.
Some of them have said, OK, here is evidence
that you do state social distancing or seeing
a lower rate of case growth or whatever.
Again, many people don't care about the facts,
but you can have a conversation about it.
Kaylie's off the deep end in Kolt world.
Trump is America first, so he won't allow
the corona virus into the U.S. Unlike awful
Obama, that's immune from fact.
You're not operating in the real world, and
Kaili often doesn't operate in the real world.
Just check out our videos about abortion.
And Trish Regan also doesn't operate in the
real world.
So it's really a perfect fit, actually, for
the Fox News audience.
Now, after this clip started to get attention,
some spokesperson for Trump said, no, no,
no, no.
What Kaili meant was Trump will allow the
virus to come here from China because he banned
travel.
OK, well, Trump banned China travel when Europe
was already actually the focus of the disease.
He was always 10 steps behind.
And maybe most importantly, even after Trump
banned travel from China, flights from China
kept coming in for a full week after that
point.
So this is really ugly, weaponised ignorance
that we're up against.
We're up against a virally spreading virus
and we're up against virally spreading disinformation
and we're up against people who seem to have
been inoculated against fact and reason.
And that's a really tough place to be.